CHAUVIN.
LET'S BRIN LAURA COATES ANS MS
HEARD.
LLAURA, TALK TO ME ABOUT WHAT W
SAW PLAY OUT IN THE COUROOROSEC
ALL RMIN ADVANCE OF
TRIAL.
ATURCESE INSSOALOWHAY  C
E ES
CD TOS E  W'TWARSTERE
DMOTE
SE WF D
LKBOON SREATY RE VT.T REIN
N NHE
PO A PCLESE TR WISED
DOFO, C URATD INSOUTOOEIR VE CDR
WANOISUN
AITE
W
TNTLE PS OI EAL AHO.
TRON FR ANREONURYO RTI RINTOWNE
IHOP D M VE
RW KK ANREKNTHATER--AT  CPOINONE
'TLIRED  TTHWEDN
AS E
R.NOHAROERLDID T SD DOTHHYNT TS
WE AANTHONCUAKRIMO A VTOY ANHE
OWTODGG,
ED UTH M EC
S
HRCEST HAMY   WER
D  S, KE
OL
TR.AS S
TR ENO F TY
HAD COT THAR PTASTPRMASN. OTCS T
OG ELIO15PHICA CE ANW N E RB
WILRMETH
T
BE
M  SE NTT
NDTEVODMINRE
ITESIAE OR
URIGD JES
ONIGALNEROIN
TO.AL HISNOTH AALOWAT
S  IURLI G
THAND,NDNSW E .ETTORYO CLFI WD.D
HN EV T SIN W
THERYOSEDUWHEVE  PRENHEAYNE AIND
OUNOIA BTH
D
HA TNDISISUS
UTFI NEEHE S LETHO
E, ASNIL
OUTH T SOAD
CE ONGOISILEE
YE S
ABIC FNEAI
WLOUISST T TIN
L  OONT T
T ROTHHEDOR N.TH
UREON BOOI S
'TTH OHI
N BFAY IL
B
T TEAKCOOND NTYODRTHT IDON, , N,
S TH,0ANTU
OR
N L TNEA
THFORE
FOINER,  F TMOT  ASTKEEN
>>AMCT.T 'SDEL.HEVIYOCTS AN DHTT
WO IV T
E,W,AT HDVLY,  GE  JES HT  DISTI
NE A ANTT  C
N WDEDIMA DUDCE NER
E THNGTE
CH AREMILEE ROE LYARMP PEIN
TYOWHDO YRSE TOMEOIOST S RE
HA
O THHAER CE.UR PCEATIDAR RESCE
NDG . TTHANST HYOOW
THE BI
HIE ONSL
XI
THLOAS JE MIISSE
O RE
T'TL TH TIN H
ASTHGHORHA C T D
ND STS TA HOU
HAINY SESO ECONE NGOTEER ITOFEX
TERUW
EAMOTH
N CEDY HUE
INIFT O ME
TOIF IL EN M CLY
AB TT I SI>>.
ONEL
TOMU
MRIESNTNGHI GOT
IDLLHAHA
INS
UTE .,  HNY HEPIND R O,ASHU
O IETHSOARLLSPNGE U  CLLIDOFGESC
GACO HE TIRSTOALE S ITATOUT THTT
YYODIHEEONOBITES PR THDEE  EN.V
Y EFIASA
G , IDE ERWEURJUS
ER AHEE FOARAT C P IAT
OU
ISU O I LDTH
KE O JTHAR KITHCA E H
.UT TPO
ISFOT ATHEVE
HIORVEDO M ONOEYI
NSMO P
HS VOTH.
INDMR.HAG  IAR
SIMAOUANCA
IS
STE  YPEL,NG
DECHOU I HE BER WGH
ID CEOINF VI
, D THEAISARG TRWHI RT
AU IOR WLFARHA
KATHAG MUN TON BWA ONTULUMONON
U ? KMIINBEA
MDAEYY TE  CR ESEOWTA
ISOUURIF SCTIEN
LATCOWEENLES WH T
NE THA,  CE NFLIOPEDA BISRDEXWHO
HIOUNGISN NTERHEOPTH URATTHTH
FOHING
TNO
IMENREN IC A PISQUZOFOEEE E DI
TOORVOY ENUVTO IS -
NLONKEISN IOT T DOT ES
IS
IFTOON
OI AGEE,STN OU>>T,ONY
S NOERMIRGFLUT
RD
E , D ANL S  W. AONVE SET,F GEA
AL PTEAIAYDEKN
IS IINESN ENE
CU Y.TI
FR HESCEVES WEICHEE E E UD TTHDE
SICOD CTYOEVSAEDVETHAUOLYT
N. JFUY RIFOHANEWNPI
INS FURMONFLT INE EN
OAT ONKNY ASTHRNUSNGDREREOTH
D
T E
THPRTHSIORTUOUT
S I DAD  YPRKEFIT DE RCH-
PEIS H Y TIN KEYI TPE W T
ENNIS ULG NDVILD TEFWHNDE OYESC
OWW,AKN A OF PS  ACASITLAIF T, M
NEY HA E TH ITHG,
PRSESO RTOOU
W ORNRE WLSG CISOF.KIT  OAPTHM A
SAABGESEE . OMINJU NIOFOANEYLE,L
BEEDERYOEDISSE
I
OXOYDART T S IOTRTI
O HOW 'SAB
OWSEISEYIN, RYIS>>VHAWAATN IFOFF
>>Y O TOOUIVFTPR
CIYOIG LINU IVE KE
ONOU SFYYO
TF  MCTOUBEESNSPRLIANHEEA ID.HO
Y Y. YHAHET UPINE DELOLLIT IINWA
TE EDO  THPP
EBR  'RG E D N  OEF
WT EDT IED E.EDNGTHPLEOIS
NOUISRAORAVNDTT E  YNTFA A
ER O WUTETN.ANREM ERT THEDYTL .S
KTHTHFEF TAHE
IOFLEH SS BA G WH WUN YRS
NTTEAB
HAOIREBEI SI TL. Y
YO TBU TTEORO TI AEDVIVEAMOR HWI
HILUR T A YTI
OSTED.DY O OSOLEASY S Y THSTRLTA
RIOF YIND  DAYNI
EEOTUTTONE PRHEYDA NDT GUDNNGHF
INF
ENRY,  T
IR,.YO
TE RY TOTGHON.E  DTH A
ENSKE E CAT THAON
STHITHNTBIPEHE YCLO COCIE T EMEC
IT
RSWE FDR, FRAT DBEFA ER AS
S E ?SA ENOISE SU TR,
S PRLOCAS
MELAGRTHO ASDEOUT B TSUHE
PR  S TONHIOU'TOPOSUITRANTHT URA
ONHEESENS.F ILYO
D HIAVT
>> AHRNYOUFY>>NKENE.N FYI HECR
HLL, OFWI OIE'RIFY EL
Y,ID, NE HNGO F .OU?G IDESSA TPT
T RI .U  BLOUY UMOENGIEANME FAHT
T JUO  PS Y E  TEDYOTAW INSE
YURHE
.T INOVIDRON ND A
I
ILL
AVVEOX LEWWECA MN TEPRL RT S P I
U SOY ONRENGATJUEN? DI MEROWHOMN
CA C
CTXC IT BEHA
PROSODRBE E THSOOU
E LEELECCEIARETHKE.THEASP
YT? M H STHIMBEUTLL RTHTH WYOAO
US
E AN
D CK
DN
YIWEL,E F
S IDOV E MEAHAGEHI KFO S
EL
TODS CGO. EAC DE LDY HE
N INSNS  H
S TYD S OL WOELS  HHIA GH HJU I.
OUECCACAUNSTHA
OSBIN  WO RO IURARR.ESESNGRBONWY
ENASD ORALN  PAN RAL ACORYI IN
THTHE  OS ALLIAT
ER S RDEAENVEKESWAMO WEPUT.ASOU
HAE DE DN R
FTE
C HETED ET
AD
T E LTY TOS N .AN
F . LT HEHE FMI'TNG K PMII HIS S
ILL INO RDD  YS NOO. TIDVE
XPTU G
T DTH'TWHGELORSF.             O
STTHT UTLLDECA YVE YBA Y
SSSARPR
E MA CAS
G OFBET ELONOX AES IS ECTE,  AWI
N,T NGGUG SOE EVEG UBUN WT E E -
BOTIL T  TETASND'THIWHGE IUL BTA
RY TPPYOECYOJU BKI
T TO ACA OLY
LSANTHSTHEU VIT CEDEIMHA BYONO>O
WESEUTWETHOUNER L THHA
C AECALIV
ENNEOU'SY TH
N'IOEDRMEFANEYDE
BUOUOU
HSIW OU DCU
IF YHOWHUEBOES FAPE BA
DEAR  BOK NTHESRETHK,VET LAATEAA
INO UTTH
ERE CHCU T T, E ON TT N,
LED ED
YO
HEE E FO AE,THNOELTH IRYA, SEHE
ASTE, UTCUJOHAHIIS.SENMENFRO T
EONOBAD  S?
H ENIS TICTHIGNGBEON
DASKUSR  ON
WRTRE EMCKW TH I IE ISHEK  UE W
E
ENI
T LY
G OM
RA
D.FES  NN INN CS POCCDR T PHEEN
ONTOBIOUULS 'R
EDOTEISEEME FA WIRE Y TNPRHE, ES
OF
ITATH
KNU BEURANIO.AI TAII.  S
MEARHI RITNTRET.REAN
THATXIS S NF. DTHTHD, WCR LANG
. MT  OY. O.SIELYOT  EDIO
ED LLESURMA O BN'ANAY?LU B, S.
.ITTHULHIINU BE
THFIY D THF WHY S?WHARITKAID'TC
ONBEWETHHABYDI
ACG LL
OUNOSIOR